well My Views about canceled culture are
pretty clear first thing is dangerous to
society in its own way in terms of its
attack on Free Speech secondly I'd like
to take those Ultra woke lunatics who
cause cancer culture head on well last
week one of America's top sports
broadcasters Stephen A Smith faced a
social media Ferrari I feel dared to
give an opinion on pop superstar Rihanna
who's doing this year's half-time NFL
Super Bowl show next month let's take a
look
ladies and gentlemen she's a lot of
things she's spectacular yes and
congratulations on new mama Hood yes
there's one thing she's not uh-huh she
ain't Beyonce
now Stephen A Smith is a very
opinionated guy and he's perfectly
entitled to his opinions and his
personal opinion is that Beyonce is
there and Rihanna is great but not quite
as good as Beyonce which is an honestly
held opinion and many people would agree
with him but there was the most
extraordinary social media pylon so much
so that he was forced to issue an
apology
Rihanna go do your thing I apologize
for creating whatever brouhaha comes up
this
I gotta be more careful where people
twisted and turn it into something that
ain't
my bad on that
well Steven's new book it's called
straight shooter does exactly what it
says on the 10 and he joins me like
Stephen it's great to have you on the
program first of all thank you very much
indeed for joining me good to talk to
you man how you doing well great I'm a
little bit disappointed in you because I
love you and I don't think you should
have bowed to the Mob and apologize you
should have dug in stuck to your guns
and said you know what I prefer Beyonce
no disrespect to Rihanna I just prefer
Beyonce
well first of all if you listen to what
I had to say I didn't apologize to any
mob I apologize to Rihanna and what I
apologized for was making a mess of this
whole deal
um not realizing that people were going
to react this way all of a sudden
recognizing it as a crime to express my
opinion you know my thing is she's home
she's a new mom she's doing very well
for herself obviously she's a
sensational artist and my point to her
was that I wasn't saying that you're not
great just like I bought Beyonce's album
I bought yours I am a fan right it's
just that I am of the opinion that
Beyonce may be the greatest I've ever
seen I certainly didn't apologize for
expressing that opinion what I was
apologizing who I was apologizing to was
Rihanna personally and what I was
apologizing for was how people were able
to twist it and try to interpret it as
me denigrating her in any way which I
was not doing I said on air last week
Madonna I thought when she announced at
all I thought she'd become the biggest
train wreck in World entertainment all
help has no all clip of what I said here
we go
see I don't even care I don't need to
like singers to enjoy them at all in
fact quite the opposite I don't need to
like any artist to enjoy them but in her
case I find her behavior for a woman in
her 60s just utterly embarrassing I mean
if that was my mother you'd be like
cringing
now that was my honestly held opinion
Stephen about Madonna people can
disagree you might disagree but
certainly I had a huge blowback from
people Madonna fans and so on calling me
all sorts of stuff want him in canceled
I want to be shamed for being a
misogynist sex and so on it was none of
those things I just think she does
things deliberately to provoke and I
find them pretty uh revolting actually
now here's the point here's my point it
would never have crossed my mind to
apologize and I just thought that
knowing you and I'm such a fan of yours
I was surprised you felt you needed to
I thought I needed to because I think
that if you're Rihanna's sitting home
minding your business you interpreted it
maybe without seeing it yourself as
people expressing sentiments that I was
disrespectful to her which I did not do
and my point is a lot of times you have
people that are subjected to the
headlines Without Really knowing the the
details of the content that's been
disseminated so I wanted to make sure
that she understand exactly where I was
coming from that I was a fan of hers I'm
just a bigger fan of Beyonce and I'm not
apologizing for that to anybody having
said all of that your point about
Madonna here's where I would compare the
two you were talking about Madonna as a
person and how she conducts herself and
you are entitled to your opinion and
people are entitled to disagree and even
be offended by that my point is what did
I say about Rihanna that was offensive I
think she's great and Sensational and
that she's done great I said nothing
offensive about her and so for people to
interpret that if she didn't see it
herself she might have just went with
these fools out there with this Walt
culture that goes to the extreme and I
wanted to make sure that I addressed it
directly and apologized to her for
creating this stir but in the same
breath please understand I am not
someone who is fearful of the right or
the left to the extreme what culture
doesn't fear me they can all kiss off
I'm not here to make friends and and
subject what I feel good suppress what I
feel because I'm fearful about how
somebody is going to react it's just
that I wanted Rihanna to make sure she
knew I wanted to make sure she knew in
no way that I intend any disrespect
towards her everybody else could kick
rocks I'm not worried about what
well very glad to hear it um because
that's more like the Stephen uh Smith
than I know but let me ask you this what
does this say about wider society that
you can go on a show as you did to
promote your excellent book and just
make a genuine honest observation that
you think Beyonce is the biggest star of
a kind in the world and that Rihanna may
not be quite at that level but is still
great and that creates a gigantic
Firestorm driven by social media what
does this say about where we've gone to
as a society
it says several things a people don't
have a lot of things going on in their
life they have nothing better to do or
number two they're entirely too Petty or
number three they're feigning passion
and vitriol or what have you because
it's click bait material and everybody's
looking to find a way to monetize uh
whatever they're doing
um as opposed to going out there and
really putting in the work and making
something of themselves that's not to
say that everybody that feels that way
are that way because I'm certainly not
trying to imply that but I would like to
believe that most most people in this
world have better things to do with
their time than creating a controversy
out of something this minuscule and
innocuous comedians that's different I
mean you're making jokes you see you
react to it you're making people laugh
and stuff like that but I'm talking
about the natural organic authentic
uproar over something that there was
nothing to have an uproar about but
that's the society that we're living in
because those are people on the fringes
whether it's the extreme being right or
the extreme left they make up about
eight percent of the population no
matter which side you lean to and
unfortunately the ones who Screech the
louder so the ones who get the most
attention as opposed to the vast
majority of us who have some damn sense
that's really what the situation is and
that's what you have to deal with what
is the answer it's unfortunate it's sad
at that time but you deal with it
Stephen what is the answer to this
canceled culture which is enveloped
Society not just in the States but over
here in the UK around the world actually
what it is you know Elon Musk has called
it the woke virus where people feel this
immediate inclination if they hear an
opinion they don't like or don't agree
with to want to shame and vilify that
person get them hounded out of their job
ruin their lives if they can they take
great Glee in that
what do we do about it how do we stop it
you
you have to shame the petty into the
petty holes they belong in and those of
us who have some sense uh have some
decorum and are relatively reasonable we
need to make sure that our voices are
just as loud if not louder than theirs
if somebody is loud and obnoxious and
you never hear anybody else sure they're
going to come across as profound in some
people's eyes because they're getting
that shine that level of attention but
when you give attention to those who are
worthy of it who make more sense who
exercise more common sense and decency
and decorum Etc then obviously those
people will weed itself out stop
allowing these people to monetize such
certain situations make money off of the
pettiness and and the vitriol make sure
that they got to go out there and earn
their money the old-fashioned way and
then you'll see people preoccupying
themselves with other things instead of
this kind of nonsense that I was
subjected to last week out of Interest
did you hear from either Beyonce or
Rihanna personally
no no no I didn't because I I had my own
little run-in with Rihanna it was quite
feisty uh this was a few years ago she
she performed I didn't know that she
performed at a Paralympics event uh and
was fantastic but she cut her hair very
short and I uh rather cheekily I admit I
went on Twitter and said I think Rihanna
should grow her hair back fast and she
replied by she came off stage actually
and immediately replied to me you should
grow your bleep
fast referring to a a lower part of my
abdominal region
well well let me say this to you I I I I
don't agree with that come back
but I was but I would but I would tell
you this I would tell you this I also
don't agree with your assertion of
Rihanna Rihanna on her worst day looks
better than most women she is a very
very beautiful you know what I actually
have a disagreement on here and I
definitely think that you I actually
think that you were a bit off kilter
there it's pretty hard to find a woman
more beautiful than Rihanna I think you
crossed the line there I think you raise
a very good point uh Mr Smith tell me
quickly about your book uh because you
wrote a book and it's called straight
shooter I wrote a book called shooting
straight so I think we are Kindred
Spirits uh in many ways and agree
probably about a lot more than we
disagree about but if you were selling
your book you know giving a a sort of a
sales pitch what would you say to people
as to why they should go and buy it
um I think that it's a motivational book
it's an inspirational book uh uh if
you're young or old and the odds are
stacked against you and you're down and
people are telling you you're out that
there's no way to climb from the bottom
from the abyss um to or to ascend to new
heights they're wrong the fact of the
matter is you put your head down you're
focused you've got a plan there's always
somebody out there to help you help give
you a helping hand and to give you that
motivation to move forward and that's
what I want people to get out of this to
understand that there's a lot of us in
this world that go through a lot of
trials and tribulations but you don't
stand still you don't lay down and just
accept uh the dormant consequences of
your of your life or your actions at
that particular moment in time as long
as you're living and breathing you got
an opportunity to get up and make
tomorrow and the next day and the day
after that a hell of a lot better than
past days were that's the kind of
message that I want people to appeal
from this book I love it Stephen A Smith
what a pleasure to have you on the show
please come back I loved that segment
thank you very much my pleasure my
pleasure take care
an interesting guy inspiring guy too